[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in
josh norman the bill's cornerback the
pride
of coastal carolina and he's partnered
with the boys and girls club of uh
crescent region
south carolina doing some great things
there
and it's a teen center that opens soon
provides a safe place for youth
between the ages of 13 and 18 years of
age
after school during the summer uh
wegmans just donated 135
000 to josh's buffalo business blitz
supporting small businesses
how's morale in buffalo josh
tell you what it's it's beyond crazy uh
i think you know these guys they could
get a stadium they would definitely come
but the 6700 that was in there i'm
telling you they sound like
60 000 so it was crazy are you outside
right now in the building
yeah kind of outside i came out here to
get away
uh for a second but um yeah everything
so far has been great
um it's just beautiful here i mean look
at you got snow and
everything going on so it's beautiful
out here
wait show me the parking lot who's got
the best ride in the parking lot
well honestly you know
when you look at it you got this this
hog right here
you know it's whose is that
pretty fancy you know is that yours
oh that's yes it's the only one that
matters
[Laughter]
uh when did you know you guys had
something special in josh allen how long
did it take
practice or games uh you know we first
got here
um all week back in i mean you want to
go to training camp really
zoom calls before the training camp and
then
you know going each and every day we got
to training camp
playing with these guys and competing i
mean talent
was out of this world we let go of some
guys early on in training camp that like
can play on anybody's roster
so we knew was gonna have a good ball
club when that happened and then we
started getting to the games
and we started to get our feet rolling
and was like okay we
could do this thing but we had a little
spot there in the middle
and then we started rolling we capped
off one win after another win and it's
like
oh we find our groove now so once we got
our groove
like okay let's let's get to the
playoffs and the playoffs came and
here we are in this it's like man we can
do this thing so
we always believed and we always had
that notion of where we were going to be
when all of it you know the dust shuttle
but now to actually truly
see it come to fruition all our hard
work and all our
dedication that we put into you know the
field and the craft and ship that we was
able to
obtain with all the pieces you know we
put a stand together you gotta give your
hats and credit off to
brandon bean and sean mcdermott for
making such a team man because they
compiled a lot of guys from
different places to come on and um be a
support cast to the guys that's already
here
what's it like when you're facing
mahomes and you know he's
in a rhythm um you know
when a guy like that is in a rhythm it's
kind of
hard to you know game plan for it's kind
of hard to get out there and stop him
but
you know we got players i i feel like on
this team that
is equipped for that and made for that
and really for these tough times they
come through
and they give us big plays game at the
game somebody is stepping up and making
a play for us and
we was evident of that last week with
taryn johnson with that 101 yard
interception return that was so
big it was like a backbreaker for them
so um we're relying on
you know our keys our our teammates to
make
more plays i think when you play a guy
like that
you can't really let him you know get
you off track of what you do
you can't be so much concerned about
what he does but
more so what you do and trying to
maintain that at all times
but are you more concerned about tyree
kill or jason kelsey
travis kelly you respect the players
but you don't you know you don't fear
them i i think there's a respect and
admiration there
uh for sure uh but there's no fear um
they have to play us too and at the end
of the day
uh we played them for they know we look
like and
um you know we know what they look like
so
hey we're gonna we're gonna play a ball
game and it gonna come down to
you know who can last the longest in
those 60 minutes and
uh it's gonna be a great great game i
can't i can't wait for it we're already
excited shoot i wish we could play
tomorrow actually today
i'm anticipating that for sure he's uh
josh norman
uh they play the chiefs the afc
championship game that'll be
at 6 40 eastern on cbs
when did you realize you were uh a meme
when uh
you got this stiff arm from uh from
henry
uh i don't know man like i don't i don't
pretty much
concern myself for such things it's a
play
you know i actually go out there josh
josh
you're in the afc title game i figured i
could ask you and you might have a
little bit of fun that derek henry
tossed you to the sidelines
i mean listen here man when you're going
after the ball you're gonna get tossed
regardless like
it's just something that you have a
knack for for me i don't look at it from
a
standpoint of what people say after the
fact i looked at if i'm gonna actually
make that play during the fact
and then coming back two days later that
we got off the field from
place that we made so i don't get too
much caught up into that man i don't
it's a laugh it's a joke i mean
we're in society now we like to see the
oohs and the odds and the glitz and the
glams of the sport
and that's great but when you're out
there the only thing you're thinking
about
is getting the opponent and getting the
ball from him so i
care less it was something to laugh
about but now you know
we're in the playoffs into the
championship
and he's not so and derek henry is not
in the afc title game so
hey man hey look respect to the man he
has 2 000 yards rushing
listen that's hard to do for anybody
only people did and he did it so hey
hats off to them and everything they got
going so
hey and uh congratulations what you're
doing with the boys and girls club of uh
crescent region south carolina and also
what you're doing uh in buffalo buffalo
business
uh blitz supporting small businesses so
that's great
great great things to be able to uh be a
part of oh absolutely we
opened a teen center in greenwood south
carolina star 2014 center
down there we and as you said we partner
the boys and girls club of america
and they explode the crescent region and
they actually helping us
open up teen center here in february
when all this is said and done
and so when that happened i that's one
of my biggest things that
i really wanted for myself in this
tenure of me being here in the league
it's just open up a team center
for the kids out there in the area they
needed the most and so the buffalo
business blitz
that we have going on now is helping out
small businesses
here in buffalo who was uh shut down
during the covet covets times
that we had during this off-season
during the seasons um
and we was just trying to give a help
and support to them so this is what
we're doing out here
uh let's get coastal carolina versus
alabama josh
why not i was talking to levi wallace
about their locker room why not
i mean hey let's class like this clash
of titans let's see what happens
my money's on coastal so it is what it
is hey
great to talk to you as always have fun
in kansas city we appreciate your time
as always
i appreciate you guys and thank you all
for having me on and we'll catch y'all
again soon
thank you that's uh josh norman the
bill's cornerback out in the parking lot
there that's great